بيروت ينضم الينا العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا بك عميد الياس
اذا المعارك المحتدمه قصف مكثف متبادل بين
الطرفين ان كان في الشرق او في الجنوب كيف
يمكن قراءه هذه التطورات الميدانيه
الاخيره
وسيله الاشتباكات مهمه هو في الشرق يعني
حول مدينه بخموط حول
كريمينا هناك تقدم هناك هجوم هناك هجوم
مضاد المعارك هناك موجوده ولكن عندما
نتحدث عن خرسان هناك القصف المتبادل لماذا
لانه بعد الانسحاب الروسي من الضفه
الغربيه اللي النهر الى الضفه الشرقيه
اصبحت القوات الاوكرانيه موجوده في
المدينه واصبح انها هو العازل الطبيعي
المهم جدا بعد ان دمرت الجسور القوات
الروسيه المنسحبه اليوم القوات الروسيه
تحاول على الضفه الشرقيه بناء دفاعات مهمه
فقط لحمايه شبه جزيره قرم وحمايه المدينه
مليتو بول يعني الطريق الام 14 التي تنطلق
من خرسان الى مليتو بول الى ماليبو بول
وبالتالي الى الشرق وجنوبا وشمالا الى
مدينه فاذن هذه المنطقه هي منطقه
التحصينات مواقع دفاعيه فقط في منطقه
الشرق هناك عمليات كر وفر وهجمات والهدف
دائما هو بخموت في ميكولايف وهذا
الاستمرار في سياسه ضرب المنشات البنيه
التحتيه الى اي مدى يضر ذلك
بالجانب الاوكراني
هذه اصبحت استراتيجيه ضرب البنى التحتيه
ضرب البونا مياه كهرباء وتدفئه وهذا الامر
سيؤثر الى حد ما على الجبهات لانه من
يقاتل على الجبهه الخلفيه هي التي تضمنه
العمق الاجتماعي والسياسي والعسكري
وعائلاتهم على سبيل المثال وحتى طرق
المواصلات هذا امر سيؤثر ولكن يبدو حتى
الان هناك عمليه سريعه همم عمليه تسريع
لاصلاحات بعد ان تم عوده ثلاث مفعلات
نوويه همم فعاليات نوويه لتزويد بالكهرباء
هناك ما يقارب يقال ان هناك
همم جنريتر او همم يعني همم من الكهرباء
ارسلت الى اوكرانيا وكانها نقطه يعني
انطلاق بانتظار ان يعني يتم اصلاح هذه همم
الشبكه ولكن بالفعل هناك تا ويبدو ان هذا
هدف استراتيجي للقوات الروسيه وعلى الجانب
الروسي كيف او الى ماذا يؤشر تفعيل انظمه
الدفاع الجوي في شبه جزيره القرم
شبه جزيره القرم هناك تهديد اوكرانيا
بضربها عندما اقتربت قوات الاوكرانيه من
خرسان اصبح مدى الهايمر على الاقل يعني
قريب من هذه المناطق تفعيلها الخوف من
المسيررات الخوف حتى من المسيرات البحريه
التي تستهدف البحريه الروسيه هذا الامر
فقط ايضا لتطويل السكان الموجودين في همم
شبه جزيره القانون لانه دائما الحديث عن
اخراج هذه السكان من هذه المنطقه لان هدف
مستقبلي للقوات الاوكرانيه ولكن اعتقد ان
هدف بعيد المدى وليس قريب وسيله لماذا
تقول انه بعيد المدى ولا تعتقد ان
اوكرانيا قد تقدم بالفعل على استهداف همم
جزيره القلب
اولا الحواجز الطبيعيه قطع نهر النيبرو
اذا من زبروجا يجب النزول الى ماليتو بول
وبالتالي قطع الجسر البري وهذا امر نتحدث
عن مئات الكيلومترات من المساحات بحاجه
الى جنود بحاجه الى سلاح بحاجه الى وقت مع
قدوم فصل الشتاء ولا يجب ان ننسى ان هناك
معركتين تدوران في الشرق يعني في منطقه
خركاب عفوا وكريمينا وايضا في منطقه بخموت
لا يمكن للقوات الاوكرانيه وليس لديها
القدره لخوض هذه المعارك كلها في نفس
الوقت
اشكرك جزيل الشكر العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي ضيفنا من بيروت